ok let's get into audience questions for
the week a lot of Boerne related
audience questions this week but let's
do it let's get right into them hey
David marianne williamson has endorsed
Bernie Sanders for president of the
United States and in the Democratic
primary could this be a turning point in
Bernie's campaign and is it likely
Bernie will select Mary Ann as his
running mate if he is the nominee so
I've been asked similar questions before
I don't know that marianne williamson is
going to figure sig figure significantly
into the nomination process nor into the
eventual presidential campaign I would
be shocked if Bernie Sanders selects
Marianne Williamson as his running mate
if I had to bet I would give pretty
significant odds against that now of
course I don't bet because I don't know
what I'm doing but if I had to bet I
would I would very heavily bet against
Marianne being Bernie's running mate I
don't believe that in any kind of
mathematical sense her endorsement of
Bernie is any kind of a turning point
but I don't think Marianne's a bad
person her message of love is a
perfectly fine message I've interviewed
Marianne Williamson before as many of
you know I'm not really on board with a
lot of her sort of woo stuff but she
struck me as a perfectly nice lady
genuine in most senses although always
with the idea of selling some of those
new-age books lingering somewhere in the
back there but I didn't see any of that
when I saw her introduce Bernie at an
event she seems to just genuinely like
Bernie Sanders
I believe she thinks Bernie would be the
best person to represent the Democratic
Party in the general election and
presumably also that he's the best
person to beat Donald Trump so I have no
ill-will whatsoever I think she's a
kooky person and I know that when I said
this during the debates that she did
make it into some people were mad
I mean research marianne williamson you
can both have a unique message of love
and and brotherhood and sisterhood among
people and whatever and it's great and
you can have some kooky New Age pseudo
science woo beliefs and she happens to
have both of them so what welcome her
support of Bernie sure Bernie Sanders is
doing nothing wrong by having her
introduced to him at a rally it's all
lovely I don't believe that she is going
to play any significant role in Bernie's
eventual in in the remainder of Bernie's
primary campaign and if he were to be
the nominee
I don't believe Maryanne is going to be
Bernie's running me if you disagree with
me let me know I am willing always to
have my mind changed I want to tell you
about one of our sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk
and now breakfast has gotten much more
boring magic spoon is a new cereal
company that has discovered how to
recreate your favorite childhood cereals
with zero sugar twelve grams of protein
and just three grams of net carbs per
serving they offer four flavors based on
the classics cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry plus the variety pack which
lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon comm slash Pakman promo code
Pakman for shipping